Do you think he should not have been banned from all these platforms?
I don't think, I do think that if you are a private company, right.
I do think, and this is where you run into this problem. Like,
I don't know if these tech companies were government utilities,
would that decrease people's likelihood of being banned? I don't know. Right.
So I'm, I'm, I,
I understand the benefit of them being treated like public utilities and people
thinking they have the right to a Twitter. Um, I've never, I don't know.
I have very little confidence. I mean,
the government is trying to roll out a vaccine in California and we've
vaccinated like five people. I mean,
in terms of what we need to do in the state. Right?
So maybe if it was a government utility, I, I do think someone like Alex Jones,
like there should be some process. So if you're going to get rid of someone,
they should have a way to defend themselves.
There should be more democratic,
a process that you can go through than just being unilaterally
taken off something. But like, then you went into the music.
Am I going to say that everyone does, or no,
if you're threatening or harassing people or threatening to kill them,
publishing their private information.
If you're committing crimes on these platforms,
obviously the people that own these platforms are going to be like, we can't,
we're not gonna allow this to happen.
So I understand that there is a line, right?
There is some people that say there is no line. Aren't really thinking,
like there is a line. I just thought that line seems to be moving all the time.
And it seems to be a very hard thing to police, but I,
I don't think you can remove a guy off everything. And then also bank accounts.
Won't give him debit cards or credit cards.
I don't know if you've talked to him about that, but like, you know,
there were financial institutions that were refusing to let him park his money
there. So, I mean,
it really does get pretty terrifying pretty quickly.
Um.
Probably without any transparency from those companies. So you're right there.
It feels like there should be a process of, uh,
just having for him to defend himself.
I think there needs to be a process for people to defend themselves. I I,
every day I wake up and I go, can I,
is something I said in a video gonna get taken out of context,
is somebody going to get angry? Is somebody going to be, you know,
I say wild stuff because that's what makes me laugh.
That's what makes my friends laugh. And that's what makes my audience laugh.
So I, I never ever people, I, you know, whatever,
whatever political side you come down on,
I think if you make your living speaking, it's always interesting to me,
if you are pro the D platform, isn't, that's odd.
It's interesting to consider a kind of a jury, uh,
con context to where, you know,
there's transparency about why you're video by bombing. Um,
Disney world might be taken down like it's, it's, uh, it gets taken down.
And then there is a, it's almost like creating a little court case. I mean,
mini court case, and not in a legal sense, but in, in the public sphere.
And then people should be able to have, you know,
you pick representatives of our current society and have a discussion about that
and make a real vote, you know,
just have like jury locks himself up in a discussion that kind of,
that kind of process might be necessary right now.
What happens is Twitter is completely, first of all,
they're just mostly not aware of everything they're doing.
There's too much stuff, but the stuff they're aware about,
they make the decision in closed doors, uh,
the meetings and without any transparency to the rest of the company,
actually, but also transparency to, uh, the rest of the world. And so,
and then all they say is we're doing,
we're making it decisions because the people,
they use things like violence, so violence equals bad.
And if this person is quote unquote inciting violence,
therefore that gives us enough reason to bend them without any kind of process.
It's. I mean, it's interesting. I'm, I'm torn in the whole thing.
If it was indeed, there's no transparency about it.
But if parlor was indeed inciting violence,
like if there was brewing, uh, violence, potential violence, where, you know,
thousands of people might die because of some kind of riot
like this, the scary thing about mob,
about when a lot of people get together, right?
Or good people like legitimately good people that love this country that don't
see enemies yet, uh, around them.
But if they get excited together and there's guns involved, it's a problem.
And then some cop gets nervous and shoots one person,
another person shoots the cop, and then there's a lot of shooting involved.
And then it goes from five people dying in the Capitol to thousands of people
dying in the Capitol.
Well, in fairness to, to defend, uh, the people that cap,
they didn't shoot the cop, they,
they bludgeoned him to death with a fire extinguisher. Yes. So I do,
I do want to just kind of put that out as a, as a defense of them. Listen,
I'm sure there was some wild going on on parlor. And I think the prompt,
here's the problem, right?
There's a lot of people that just want to go on these sites and say,
they want to kill everyone. Yeah. And the problem is, you know,
at what point do you shut them all down? Like,
I think a lot of people are just living in a world where they're powerless.
They don't have any political power. They don't have any economic power. Right.
They can't throw their money around. Uh, they don't have health care, their,
their job security. Isn't great. Uh,
they might be living in a community that doesn't have the resources.
They would like it to have. Uh, they're they're not happy and thrilled.
And then they have these sites where they can go on and just say, man,
I'd like to burn it all down and distinguishing a guy
blowing off steam and saying wild stuff from a genuine threat is a very
hard thing to do. You know? Like I ha I've threatened to kill.
Uh, I got banned from Airbnb. I threatened to kill the people, um,
that bad B comedically, comedically,
this is a joke. I'm not going to kill you. This is a joke.
Cause I'm blowing off steam and I'm angry.
Do you know how many people that my parents, like, my dad's like,
I'm going to kill this guy.
My mom's like, I'm going to kill. Yeah. And, and they were talking about.
But it's, but none of it ever happened, but we should be.
I think you, you, you have to create a space for people to threaten,
to overthrow the government. Yeah. As long as they don't violently do it. Like,
I mean, does that make any sense? Like, I mean,
as long as they're not going to go hurt innocent people,
what are you going to do? Like there's so many people out there that she's,
that's why a lot of these things like, you know, four Chan and the sides,
a lot of people going on there,
they just want to say the most up because they it's the thing that it gives
them, they can laugh or they can release steam. And it's, it is a mature,
it is stupid. It's not productive. It's not, you know,
but at the end of the day, if you're not going to give people health insurance,
you got to give them something. It's like when someone in this country dies,
that everyone disagrees with, right? Political figure media figure,
a lot of people dance on their grave online. And then everyone,
people goes dead and the other side will always do it.
Like if a conservative dies and everyone goes, great. Conservatives goes to,
this is grotesque that you, and then when RBG dies, they all have parties.
And the conservatives go crate. Um,
you have to let people in this country enjoy the deaths of their enemies
because they don't have much else. Again, if you gave them other things,
you might say, guy, you can go get any operation. Why don't you stop?
But if,
if they're working for wages and you haven't figured out a way to,
to treat them, uh, treat their cancer diagnosis.
And they don't like, I mean, life, you know, it, it, you know, you gotta have,
you got to derive pleasure from something.
Yeah. It's an interesting point. That anger is a good valve like to,
for if your life is suffering,
that there's something very powerful about anger,
but I still have hope that it doesn't have to be mean that kind of channeling
into anger, uh, that then becomes hate.
Let us into a lot of troubles in human history. Yeah. You have to be careful,
uh, empowering people too much in that anger. Especially I think my,
I think I understand why people were nervous about parlor,
about Twitter and so on. Yeah.
Because all that talking about violence was
now paired with let's get together at this location that this was a
new thing.
Like it's not just being on whatever platform talking
it's saying we're going to in physical space meet.
And then everybody got all these platforms got nervous. Well,
what happens when all these talkers, all these angry people that are just steam,
uh, letting off steam meet in a physical space. Uh,
and there was probably overreach, uh, almost definitely overreach,
but I can understand why they were.
I agree. There doesn't seem to be.
And this is when Trump got elected and when you have like, whatever you have,
right? Whether you have riots in Portland and Seattle,
where you have the Antifa people doing crazy things, you have like, you know,
the people storming the Capitol. There never seems to be a ton of, uh,
an examination of why these ideas are becoming popular. Right?
Why are people so angry? What is leading people to this? Why are we here?
What about their lives is to the point where they need to show up at these
places. And like, and obviously there's,
there's going to be people on the fringe. They'll always be the mentally unwell.
They'll always be people that want to destroy society.
But when you look at how popular large, long discredited things,
whether it's fascism, you know, totalitarian, communism,
all of these things are like, why are they back? Why are they back in a big way?
And why are,
why are people so fed up with the status quo that they're finding,
you know, solace in the most extreme,
uh,
discredited theories of how to run and operate societies theories that have led
to deaths. A lot of it. So to me, I'm like,
if those people at the Capitol, yes.
If they were going to work, if there's, you know,
if they were able to go out and drink at Chili's,
if they were able to get a checkup, right?
Like if their job paid a little bit better,
and I'm not saying that this is all the reason, right?
I'm sure that there's a lot of people there that are doing quite well.
And they're still nuts,
but like the anger and the rage that's boiling to the surface of the
society,
does it come from the fact that across the board,
people in very different areas and with very different political beliefs,
feel like they are being over and there's nothing they can do about it.
That's what the baseline to me,
they look at the people that run the country and run the world.
Whether they're tech Titans, the guys that you talked to,
or whether they're people that run the government,
whether they're people that run large banks, large media companies,
the people that have created this kind of infrastructure that everyone lives in,
these people are incredibly powerless. And when you push people to that point,
logically, sadly,
and unfortunately the next thing does seem to be violent.